Hey everybody welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the world's best female Ultra runner
straight up and when it comes to the really long stuff,
races in excess of 200 miles,
she is arguably the best period.
A two time ultra runner of the year
named one of the 50 fittest athletes in the world
by sports illustrated.
Courtney Dauwalter beat everybody
men included at the Moab 240 which she won
by a staggering 10 hours
and at the Big Dog's Backyard Ultra,
where she clocked in astonishing 283 miles.
She also won the women's division at the Western States 100
and UTMB the two most prestigious Ultras in the world
and of course, many other victories along the way,
Courtney is a humble master of mental grit
and boundary busting physical prowess,
but she's also just super fun to be with.
So please hit that subscribe button and let's get after it.
This is me and the great Courtney Dauwalter.
(upbeat music)
It's so nice to meet you thank you for coming out to do this
I really appreciate it I've been looking forward
to this for a very long time.
Yeah thank you.
How are you feeling these days?
Good yeah.
Yeah.
I'm excited the snow is starting to melt in Colorado so.
Well it's June I hope.
Yeah it takes a while.
Yeah so it's getting warm out there
you're totally healed up
after the Colorado trail bronchitis episode.
Yeah totally healed up
I probably only had a couple months
where I noticed that in my lungs last year
and then yeah it was kind of like all green lights
once they healed.
Right.
And you're getting ready to tackle a pretty
auspicious double you're gonna do UTMB in August
or in Hard Rock 100 in July 1st right
and then right on the back of that a month later UTMB.
Yeah 200 mile races it'll be really cool.
Short ones.
Yeah yeah.
(Courtney laughs)
I don't I mean it's just a fun challenge
I think they're like six weeks apart
so I have no idea what the time between will look like
I think just kind of figure that out as I go
and try to be ready to rumble at both of them.
When you say you have no idea that's sort of revealing
in terms of your approach to your training, right?
Like you're this intuitive when it comes to
how you approach your routine.
Correct yeah there's no plan.
That's so crazy.
You literally do you wake up in the morning
and then make the decision or do you plan the day before,
do you plan a week?
I mean you must have a general idea
other than like okay I typically put in 100 miles a week.
You must have a little bit more of a specific sense
of what you're trying to accomplish
like walk me through this so I better understand
because you play it off like with this very aw shucks
disposition but I know there's more going on.
Nope it's all aw shucks.
No I so every day I do wake up and after drinking coffee
I'll figure out what I'm doing that day
there's no like, there's no plan going into a week
what the days might hold
but I will know when races are
and I will know like when I can go
kind of hog wild with training
and when I should pull in the reins a little bit
and be smart because there's a race coming up
or I should focus on something specific
like climbing in the mountains
or trying to run a little bit faster
so I'll know those things it's not totally winging it
in that way but every single day
it's deciding how I feel physically and mentally
to determine what the run will be.
Is there any scheduling of like okay on these days
I typically go longer and these are more tempo days
or technique days or speed focus days?
Not really.
Or you just go out and go long pretty much
and just switch up the terrain
based upon what you're training for?
Yeah a lot of the days are just long days
but I'll do intervals and stuff
I sometimes won't even know when those are going to happen
once I'm on the run there's just a few routes that I'll do
where there's a hill that I really like to do intervals on
so if I get to that spot on the route
and I feel it then I'll pop some into it
and if not then I just carry on.
And does that come into play like you
it doesn't appear that you've ever over trained, right?
Do you know when to back off
so you don't kind of tip over into that terrain
where you're gonna wear yourself down too much
and not be able to recover is that all on feel as well
or have you just not,
you have such a capacity you're such a workhorse
that you've never hit that place.
No I've made mistakes for sure
or just tried to keep loading it on but
I think that's part of what I like about
not having a plan is that I get to just figure it out
by making those mistakes.
So run myself into a ground one week
and realize like that was a few too many miles
so now I can go from there and try
and hone in on what I'm doing a little bit.
And no coach input?
No, no.
No!
I did though I mean I grew up with fantastic coaches
so in high school and in college I worked with some
amazing people and I think like they showed me
all the types of workouts that you can be doing
it wasn't for ultra running but
like I'll still draw on that
and use some of what I learned from them
to decide what I might do.
What's interesting about that is
you have a science background
you are a science teacher, right?
So why not avail yourself of like the science
like oh periodization seems to work
or maybe you're already doing that I don't know
but there's a lot of athletes
and you see this much more in track and field
or in triathlon than you do in trail running
where people get really into the graphs
and the heart rate and the power output
and all these all these data points around sleep performance
and all of that
and get mired in that in terms of trying to figure out
how to crack the code on training.
Yeah that's exactly what I don't want.
Right in your scientific approach?
Yeah.
Because, why not?
I mean, I'm having so much fun with how it is right now
and I don't have a reason to change it
I also, I don't know I think that without a plan
I do much better actually listening to my body
so I pay more attention if there's no schedule
and there's no workout written down
then I can really tune in
and react you know if it's an off day
then I don't do a workout
I don't do a run.
Right you can pull.
You have no problem like pulling the plug.
Yeah and I don't feel any guilt
because there was nothing planned anyways
I don't know because I haven't had a plan
or a coach in ultra running but I feel like I could get
like really attached to it if I had it
and then disregard any symptoms
or signs that I should change course.
Right thinking, oh I need to accomplish this
because the coach said this is what I need to do
and then that ends up corrupting
this sort of perfect situation that you have for yourself.
It's not perfect but I think if it's fun
and I'm enjoying every day and I'm still like,
I'm still getting in the miles
and the workouts that I'd like
then I'm gonna stick with it for now
I can see tons of benefits of having a coach
but for now I would.
Keep it this way.
Yeah.
It's working, right?
Don't mess with it.
I do think that happiness piece
is a big part of your secret sauce
like you're able to find the joy in all facets of this
and that seems to be like fuel, right?
A lot of people in this subculture they are powered
by oh I'm just the grit and how hard it is
and I'm gonna really embrace the suffering
and not from a victimhood place
but kind of like a more hardcore relationship
to the difficulty of completing these races
and the training that goes into them
and you're just having fun like all the time
like Billy Yang is here
and I texted him the other day
and I told him you were coming
and he's like oh that's so great 100% approval rating
in the trail community like there's nobody
that doesn't love Courtney
and no matter how hard the race is
or whatever you're enduring internally
you always have a smile on your face
you always have a moment to give a high five to a little kid
or to say a nice thing to a volunteer on the course
and that takes you know a conscious effort
like there's a certain disposition that you have
that seems to be unwavering.
Well thank you.
We're so lucky to be able to choose something like this
to do with our time.
So I think if you're not having fun with it then
I don't know maybe reconsider some things.
(Courtney chuckles)
Yeah but fun isn't I mean it is fun
and everything about trail running is awesome
but for a lot of people fun isn't in like the top five
adjectives how they describe their participation in this.
So how do you keep that in check
it's just natural to you, right?
It must be in Minnesota.
Yeah.
(Courtney laughs)
I like how you don't seem to overthink things too much
I think that's also there's a lesson in that, right?
Like you just you're having fun you go out
you train really hard.
You go in with a smile
you're a competitor but
in your kind of list of priorities like
keeping it fun keeping it light staying present
with what you're doing seems to be the priority.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm sure every interview you do
they ask you, how come you're so much better
than everyone else, right?
And you always have a very diplomatic response to that
but I don't wanna let you off the hook on this
like somebody who's crushed it,
there's these famous stories about
you winning the Moab 240 by 10 hours
and all these other races that you've destroyed everybody
men included you seem to sort of shrug it off
but you must think at some point like how come
this is the case like what is,
when you go to sleep at night,
do you does it ever like do you ever ponder
like what is the differentiator between you
and your fellow competitors?
No I don't ponder.
(both laughing)
oh man I mean I think like
everyone can be pushing themselves
so I don't I can't compare like
what it's like in someone else's body or head
and then what's going on in mine.
So I have no idea but I do know like
I enjoy that place that we get to go to in these ultras
where it hurts really bad I think that's pretty cool
and I mean that's got to help like not avoiding it but
wanting to get to it has got to be like
factored in there somehow.
Yeah sure, okay let's go a little bit deeper.
Tell me a little bit more about,
what that is when you reach that point
or that limit or that place where you feel like
you can't put one foot in front of the other
like what is the like the lesson
that you find for yourself in that?
So I call it the pain cave that place
and I guess like probably four or five years ago
I viewed the pain cave as like this place
that you should try to put off as long as possible
in a race like make your pain cave be as far away from you
as you can
and if you arrive to it
then you just sit in it
and you try and survive the pain cave.
But in the past couple years,
I mean it's just a mindset, right?
It's like all in our heads this thing
and in the past couple years it's been
the place I want to get to
so like changing it to a place where I get to celebrate
that I made it there and then that's where
the work actually happens.
So making the pain cave bigger
is how I view it instead of like pushing the pain cave away
and I think I mean our minds are so powerful
so even just like changing the story line
makes it a whole different game.
Right so what is the story that you,
like what is the the script that you flip
when you're in that headspace
and it's getting really hard.
Yeah it's like perfect this is what we wanted
like now we get to actually do the hard work of
making the cave bigger and so it's like picturing a chisel
and just like making tunnels in my pain cave in my brain.
Right.
(Courtney laughs)
You actually visualize that?
Yeah I'm super visual.
Yeah I like that it makes it very visceral
and like real if you can,
it's not just a mantra and mantras are great
I'm sure you have mantras
but actually creating that three-dimensional image
in your mind.
Yeah and all I mean it's just telling myself
a different story about that place where it hurts so bad
where before it was like surviving it
and now it's like this is so cool we made it here
and now we work.
Yeah it's funny I've been doing this podcast thing for
a couple years at this point
and I've had a lot of people on who have done hard things
and I have psychologists and psychiatrists
and mindset experts and everybody kind of comes to the table
and they're like this is how you do it
and it's like step one two three
and like when your mind does this
and you're just like well I just you know like you just like
it's very refreshing because what it does is it dispels
this myth that it has to be complicated
or that there is a right or a wrong way like you're just
embracing life and all its colors
and have figured out this thing that works for you
but it's welcoming to people because you're saying
like look you know I'm doing this
you can do this too like there's a what's the right word
I mean welcoming to repeat myself I think is what it is
like you're creating space for other people to see
greater possibility in themselves
because of that relatability.
Well thank you.
Yeah.
It's very kind.
Yeah no I think
it's powerful, it's really powerful.
In the equation of mind versus body
like how do you think about that
like how much of it is physical prowess versus mental grit?
It's both for sure and I think in an ultra
it trades back and forth between the two
so like maybe for a while your physical
has to pull more of the weight because it can
and then if that's giving out maybe the mental takes over
for a while.
So I think they tag each other out
back and forth where you need them for sure
like physically it's hard to run this far
but mentally you can like move your feet
much farther than you think.
Right yeah ultimately I think the differentiator
is in the mental game
because everybody especially at the elite level
is training really hard
and there's only so much training that you can do
before you get injured or you over train, right?
So when you toe the line at the starting line
you can be assured that everybody
who's a threat to your dominance
has put in the work that you've put in, right?
So the person who's gonna win it's gonna come down to
who's gonna crack mentally when the tough gets going.
Yeah and like who can problem solve efficiently
or not let problems that come up
ruffle their feathers too much,
I think that's huge in ultras.
Yeah just being able to maintain
that positive disposition.
Yeah.
Rather than oh no this is terrible thing awesome
this is what it's about, right?
Yeah exactly.
(both laughing)
How do you keep a smile on your face
and tell jokes and do all that stuff
when you're so freaking exhausted.
(Courtney laughs)
Jokes help everything.
Yeah.
That's part of the strategy sneaky.
Yeah I'm actually really bad at telling jokes
so it's like a mental game for myself
to try and tell a joke with the correct punch line
so maybe it's like a-
Making sure
that you're still-
A sanity check, yeah.
It is so interesting that equation
between mental and physical
like we were chatting before the podcast I was in Utah
the last couple days I joined the Iron Cowboy for day 91
on his conquer 100 insanity quest.
So cool.
And that guy is a master of the mental game
and he's somebody who's so physically strong
but also somebody whose mental game
so far exceeds his physical capabilities
that this guy's willing to just completely break his body
like he will not crack there's no way he's gonna give up
for a physical reason.
His mental game is so strong
that he will literally run his body into the ground
and do irreparable damage before he pulls out of this thing
which is worrisome I think but also impressive
and one of the things I noticed
I walked a marathon with him the other day
is just his ability to remain positive
under all circumstances
and there's so many people that are congregated around him
and they all want a piece of him
and he makes time for every single one of those people
and then finishes the day
and always like spontaneously delivers
some impassioned inspirational speech
for everybody to take home with them
and the kind of presence of mind
that you have to have to do that
I think is really the differentiator
and what you do like the way that you carry yourself
like what you do is the way you do it is different but
in the Venn diagram like it's that positivity piece I think
that is really powerful.
Yeah well thank you.
So what's his mood like as he's walking?
Well you don't know what's going on internally
because he refuses to say anything negative.
Okay.
So no matter
what's happening he's like it's awesome this is great
Yeah.
It's this is like we're just we're just doing it man
and I'm like are you okay?
Yeah.
That's cool.
I think he is like he he seems genuinely in a good place
right now and he's had his ups and downs of course
over the last 93 days or whatever it is
and he will have completed it hopefully
by the time this goes up but it's there's so much to learn
by just observing somebody like that.
Yeah for sure, what you project out I mean hearing it
like you're hearing it in your head
but when you say it out loud
it can make a huge difference.
Right it makes it real.
Yeah.
Or more real at least.
I've told so my husband is often the crew at my races
and beforehand we're always like I don't know I tell him
just don't ask me how it's going during
because if it's going bad I don't need to tell you that
like you know and if it's going good
we don't need to say that either
let's just like carry forward.
Right, right, right.
'Cause it does nothing to tell you
how bad my legs hurt right now.
Is that outlook something you've always had
or something that you've developed or learned?
To not want to share how it's going?
No, no just being like understanding
the power of positivity and having that kind of fortitude
around protecting your state of mind.
Like is that a Minnesota thing
is that the way your parents raised you
is that something you learned as an athlete in high school
or is that just Courtney.
Yeah I feel like ultra running has taught
a lot of it to me.
When you're in those 100 or 200 mile races
you can learn a lot about what your brain can do
and what's helpful from your brain
but for sure it's got to come a little bit
from my upbringing from my parents, my coaches,
my friends and just examples.
What do you think about,
I mean your your accomplishments put you in the bull's-eye
of this ongoing, I don't want to call it a debate,
a conversation around the role of male versus female
in terms of prowess in the Ultra world, right?
Like the longer, the science basically proves that
the longer the distance is the less of a difference
sex makes, right?
So these 240s like these super long races
like whether you're male or female
seems to not make very much of a difference
and it's one of the few sports in which the women
can like crush the dudes.
I think as the distance increases
it becomes a little more equal
for sure because then it is a lot in your head
and it's about persistence and problem solving
and some stubbornness,
all those factor in quite a bit as you're out there
for over 24 hours.
Right.
I think like Big's Backyard is a great example
of a format that I think is pretty equal in what's possible
and who might win it every single year
where it's that four mile loop every single hour
line up on the hour every hour and do it again.
Yeah.
Until no one will anymore.
Right it becomes a battle of will
as much as anything else, right?
And I wanna talk about that in a minute
'cause I think that's fascinating.
But being a science teacher former science teacher, right?
It makes me think perhaps there is
some evolutionary advantage that females developed
as the child rearers that they are
they have they carry with them like a deeper reservoir
of psychological endurance and capacity versus men, right?
It seems to like it would make sense
I don't know if anybody studied this.
Yeah I have no idea I think
it would be a cool thing for someone to focus
their studies on if they aren't already.
Yeah it's wild I remember
like before you were born
when I was after I was I grew up as a swimmer
and after college I moved to New York city
and my roommate this guy Matt Nance was a teammate of mine
very good swimmer much better than me
and he decided to do the race around Manhattan
which is a 28-mile swim around the Island of Manhattan.
Jeez.
And at this time I had no interest in any into
I was like go go for it like I'm not interested
and he ended up getting second place
and I think he I can't remember this was like 1990
I think he broke the course record
but he got beat by a 15 year old girl from Australia.
Wow.
This girl Susie Maroney who ended up winning that race
a bunch of times maybe three times or something like that
so at a 28 mile swim like she just she just crushed him
and she beat him by like five minutes
or something like that.
Really.
Yeah.
A sprint finish?
No I think she had a good lead on him.
Okay.
Yeah at that point.
But it goes to that point of
when you reach a certain distance
I don't want to say gender 'cause it's not gender
it's sexual it's what you call it sexual genetics.
Really don't play the factor that they do
in other sport pursuits.
Yeah I mean I think it it gets closer for sure
I would love to just I mean 200s are kind of new
so I would love to see how over the years
with if there's more men more women competing
like just get more people out there
and see what happens because I think
I mean those 200s are fun because there's like
not a ton of information about
how they're done
or what's the formula to do this as fast as possible
whereas like there's tons of 100 mile races
that I mean you can look at people's
splits you could you know read about
their very specific training like
there's all sorts of information about that
and the 200s I think it's just a little less known
and there's a few more variables that make it hard to.
Right, yeah it's at the cutting edge
of where this sport is going
I mean it's crazy how much the sport is blown up
and the fact that so many people sign up
for 100 mile races now is like wild.
Yeah they all sell out.
I know yeah and it's weird how the mine goes well
okay 200 like as if it's somewhat the same thing.
Yeah.
(Courtney laughs)
Like it's only double like the longest thing
you can ever imagine, right?
And how many people are actually signing up for 200 miles
I mean in maybe in five or 10 years
it will be like the 100s are right now, right?
I think so.
But there's so little,
it's so new right that you're one of the pioneers here
trying to figure out how to optimize performance
at that distance.
It's a fun one to play with.
Do you wish that the races were like 300 miles?
Absolutely Yes.
400 miles
like the longer the better, right?
Like keep going.
I know when you were on Rogan
there was some discussion about a 500 mile race.
Yeah that hasn't happened yet
but like the Colorado trail that I tried is about 500 miles
and so I was kind of looking for
starting to figure out that distance with that.
Right so that was your first FTK attempt
that was sort of a COVID inspired pursuit, right?
Like all the races were canceled
so you were gonna tackle this trail
which takes you from Durango to Denver.
Correct.
500 miles.
Yeah.
You got a little
hiccup though.
Yeah.
What happened?
Well oh man it's a beautiful trail
I mean it's this beautiful single track
that goes over tons of mountain ranges
through the state of Colorado
and I'd been eyeing it for a few years
but the pandemic and all the races being canceled
for sure suddenly made it like
I mean we had a wide open summer to just go for it
so I ended up making it about
300 and I don't know five miles
and then was put in the ER
because my lungs just weren't working
like they were supposed to.
Yeah you had to be put on like oxygen, right?
Yeah it was weird because it started early
on like right when I started the trail,
I remember commenting to my crew at one of the stops like
everything feels amazing
but my lungs just are being lazy right now
I thought they just weren't turning on like the rest of it
but I figured they just needed some more hours
and then they would be,
they would realize what we were doing
and they would come with.
All right it comes around like that's that thing in ultra
is where you can't really make a informed decision
about what's going on or how you feel based on the moment
'cause it changes.
Yeah exactly.
But it just kept getting worse.
So I was like wheezing and coughing up a lot of things
and it was preventing like any good forward motion
but also like sleep wasn't possible anymore
because every time I laid down I was just like wheezing
like I was breathing through a tiny straw.
Right and you had crew with you the whole way?
I did yeah.
I had a fantastic group.
So you were never,
you couldn't have been a situation where
you were out of cell range or anything like that
and in real jeopardy.
Yeah I always had a crew,
I always had someone running with me who had like a
satellite thing that they could communicate
so we could have figured it out
if anything had really gone to the garbage
but my crew just like made the call at 305
where that we had stopped for a rest stop
and they had been watching this get progressively worse
over the course of these days
and then finally they were like we got to just
go to this hospital nearby
and get you checked out and beforehand I had told them like
You know what we're trying to do so if you decide something
about like how much I should rest or not rest or eat
or not eat like I trust you 100%
because I know my brain is gonna turn to mush
and so when they said that I mean for sure
I needed a little explanation of like,
I've been wheezing for hundreds of miles at this point like
I thought we were just gonna take that wheeze to Denver
like it was coming all the way.
That's where like maybe you don't have a coach
but you need some third-party intervention here
because your mental toughness
will forbid you from stopping.
Yeah I mean even coming into that spot I had told them
like I just want to grab a slice of pizza
and then let's keep going and they were like no
please stop and rest.
So I stopped to rest and they were like
hey we're gonna take you to the hospital
and even on the drive to the hospital in my head I was like
I'm just gonna tell this doctor what I'm doing
and he's gonna say that's fine go back out there.
(both laughing)
As he's putting
oxygen on your face-
Everything is okay.
And saying you're not going anywhere, right?
I'm sure they were really worried
I mean there was a sense that,
that something could be really wrong.
Yeah and I mean hindsight like I'm so thankful
that the crew made that tough call
because they were as invested in it as I was,
they didn't want to pull the plug
and that then the doctor kind of painted the picture of
this could have gone really far South
if they hadn't brought you in.
Right do you think it's that thing
where you probably had some really low-grade infection
but you're out there crushing it
and it just depresses your immune response, right?
So it allows that infection to take root
in a way that if you were just sitting at home on the couch
you would have been fine.
Yeah I think it had to have been something like that
because of how it felt at the beginning
where I wanted my lungs to wake up and they weren't
and it feels like something was brewing in there
but with acute bronchitis they don't have like
they can't pinpoint the cause.
Sure yeah and in these super long races
it's those tiny little things that
can end up burying you, right?
Yeah which is why it's so cool
I mean the longer the race gets or the longer the
challenge you're taking on gets the more puzzle pieces
there are that get involved
and I think just playing around with those every time
it makes you better at doing the puzzles but also like
it's just a fun game to me.
Yeah so there's events like that
this self-styled like I'm gonna tackle this trail
and do it faster than anybody
there's the structured races like the Moab 240 or UTMB
which is kind of like the super bowl of trail races
and then there are these last man standing races, right?
The backyard ultra that you referenced earlier,
which I think is such a cool format.
Yes.
Do you, like is there one of those formats
that you enjoy best like I feel like
the Backyard Ultra format, the last man standing
kind of thing is perfectly suited for you.
Yeah I love those I love all the events though.
They just change in what I love about them like
a 240 or 100 mile race I love
because it's usually a really cool course
you're getting to explore with your feet
and then ones like these loop courses
it's more like exploring in your brain
of how to go a little bit deeper.
Right so for just so like
there's a percentage of the audience that is probably
a super fan of yours
and knows everything that you've done
but there's also a large percentage of them for
whom perhaps this is their first introduction to you
so let's talk about what this Backyard Ultra situation is
you do this four mile loop right
and basically you they're on the hour essentially.
Yep.
They're on the hour so you run four miles
and however long it takes
and then you just have to start the next loop
at the top of the hour and then you just keep going
until no one's left.
So the you don't know how long the race is gonna be.
Exactly.
(Courtney laughs)
Right and so you just did this past year
and ended up running 283 miles
that's correct it's like 67 loops is that right?
Yeah 67.
You're the man, you're the science person.
Right.
A lot of loops.
67 or 68.
Until it was just you and Harvey Lewis.
Yeah.
Right?
Yeah, who's an amazing human
and it was just the two of us from 200 miles on.
So the way the race works is everyone starts all at once
and then every loop you're starting again all together
so you're never you can't like get ahead
by a certain amount of time
or bank time anywhere it's one hour
and that's it.
Reset the clock every lap.
Yeah and you can either quit
and refuse to start another lap
or you can miss the hour cut off
and that's how the field
just starts getting smaller
and smaller.
You get eliminated.
So it ended up with Harvey and I at about 204 miles or so
and we're I mean the cool part about this format is
you need each other.
Because once it's, once you're the last person standing
the race is over.
You can't keep going.
Yeah you don't get to keep doing those four mile laps
even if you feel fine.
So Harvey and I were like full on
let's work as a team we wanna get over 300 miles
how can we help each other
and we talk on the loops like,
what do you need?
What do I need?
How do we keep this train rolling.
But then part of it is also
you've gone so far that you need to like
really just focus on like not imploding yourself.
Right.
And so there were quite a few laps
where we were both just like totally focused inward
on keeping it moving.
Yeah but that is beautiful and very unique
in that your main competitor must become your ally
if you really wanna push the envelope
and see what's possible for each of you.
I think it's so cool and that to be going that far
you both need so many things to have gone right for you
like that's a far ways to run with your feet
so there's all these like hurdles along the way
that you have to navigate
and to have two people have days like that
is really special.
Right.
But I think I mean the whole field is like a team
everyone wants everyone to keep going
the more numbers you have getting into
those higher distances the more likely
everyone is to keep going farther
because if you're surrounded by 10 people
it feels less crazy
than if you're surrounded by one person.
Right, right, right, yeah it goes back to that mental game
it's the same notion that when prior to
Bannister breaking the four minute mile mark
people thought it was impossible he breaks it then suddenly
all kinds of people are breaking it
like it's so strange that that's the way
the human mind operates.
Yeah.
But it is true.
It's very true.
Yeah but did you feel like you could have kept going
if there was somebody like Harvey taps out.
Yeah I mean yes I was set on continuing on
and in the moment I felt like I could do more but
you never know like that the race is as crazy as it is
because one bad hour can take you out
and then suddenly you're done.
Or one bad footstep where you roll your ankle
or something like that happens.
Yeah, so yeah I was when he dropped
I had gotten into this really good zone
I was like kind of robotic through the loop
and I knew my spots where I ran
and I knew my spots where I walked
and it was like just put it on autopilot
and yeah I was kind of having fun like being a robot.
And where does your mind go like what's happening
are you daydreaming are you focused on what you're doing
are you listening to music an audiobook
like what is that about?
So when he stopped it was in the night
and in the night sections we switched to a road out and back
and there's music allowed in the night
so I think I was blasting some music
and then I was I think I was just like really embracing
the robot mentality of like
don't think about anything just do
and like stay right where your feet are
because that one any ultra really
but that format in particular if you project too far ahead
like how much farther are we gonna be going,
are you kidding we have to run until sunrise
or like or you start thinking about
how the other person is looking
and like they'll never quit.
Yeah.
Then it can get into your head
and spiral pretty quickly.
Yeah now that's helpful.
No.
You just have to be where your feet are, right?
Yeah but that's a discipline.
Yeah it's hard but I'll even like talk outside,
I'll talk out loud to myself like no stay right here
if I start thinking ahead too far.
Yeah what else do you tell yourself.
(Courtney laughs)
Well mostly it's like stay here
and then this is fine
and I'll just say that over and over.
This is fine, this is fine.
This is fine.
We're good.
No matter what.
And when you come in at the conclusion of a loop
obviously you're eating you're trying to rest
like what does that routine look like
and what is the sleep piece.
Yeah I think this is the one where
I mean just doing the race format
you learn so much from it
and seeing you know what's helpful
what does five minutes feel like?
What does eight minutes feel like?
Of sleep.
Learning all of that or just time like
I mean we rarely look and see what five minutes feels like
when we're just like in normal life
but when you're in this format
five minutes is really important
and you need to use it fully.
Right.
Like everything should have a purpose
and so I think I was averaging daytime loops at like
maybe 48 minutes or 50 minutes
and then nighttime loops because it's that road
out and back it's a little easier
and so I was probably coming in at more like 45.
So you're getting anywhere between 10 or 15 minutes?
Yeah at night I was, we had a really good routine of just
I would come in the little tent I had a cot set up
and I would shovel some bites of food
and then I would lay down and I'd have like 10 minutes until
the two-minute whistle blew
and then I would get up maybe drink some things
and then get back out there
and even if I wasn't falling asleep I would just lay there
pretending like I was sleeping.
Yeah.
And just convincing myself that that pays off also.
Were you able to fall asleep though
a bunch of times?
Sometimes yeah for sure.
So there's the famous story of in the Moab 240
you got one minute of sleep for the whole thing
but you felt like you slept for hours or something, right?
Yeah fully recharged after one minute.
Is it really one minute?
It was.
It was that's so crazy.
So crazy I thought my pacer had tricked me
I thought he let me sleep for 45 minutes there
it was 60 seconds.
You're mad at him.
Yeah.
(Courtney laughs)
Why'd you let me oversleep
Yeah.
Now you're getting,
you could get like 10 minutes of sleep.
Yeah I've never been able to replicate that one minute
nap though like I did another 200 mile race
the Tahoe 200 and I was trying
I was hoping for that magic.
I know how to do this now.
Yeah I totally thought I had figured out
the sleep thing
and then I couldn't get it to work again.
So I mean that keeps me coming back to these as well
as like you think you learn something
you think you have a puzzle piece figured out
and then you got to throw it back in and start again.
Do you think that that the sleep deprivation
part of the whole thing is something
that some people are better at than others
or do you think is this hard for everyone?
Like I feel like maybe you're well suited to manage that
maybe better than other people
like is that part of something you would consider
to be an advantage?
Maybe I'm not sure though I think.
Yeah you don't think about it.
(both laughing)
That's it that's my answer for everything.
Right yeah well listen it's working for you
don't think about it.
We did it we figured it out.
There's nothing you could do about it
either you're good at it or you're not, right?
yeah but I've, so I'm still learning
and I'm like I love that I can use myself
as this guinea pig and just test things and see
and like Johann Steen is another runner
who has done backyard races
amongst many other things
and watching him the first year
at the Backyard race that I went to,
he would come through a loop sit down
and immediately be sleeping, every single lap, that year
and so he's like nailed it and I would like to figure it out
so I could nail it like that.
We'll be back in a sec but first if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change" featuring excerpts from
Poignant Essays by and glorious photography
of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing
this podcast it's a gorgeous artful compendium
of the show and copious wisdom shared therein
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available
on our website, signed copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today
visit RichRoll.com/vc, that's richroll.com/vc.
All right let's get back into it.
So as a tinkerer or somebody who is experimenting
but is also self-coached
like what is something that you've learned
over maybe even the last two or two and a half years
that you're doing now that you weren't doing in 2018
or 2019 like what where are the kind of evolutionary hacks
in your training or your kind of strategy with these races.
That's tricky, I think getting on trails more
and yeah playing on mountains more has changed.
More play.
Yeah and then I think just learning from all the problems
that come up like you do these long races inevitably
there's problems that come up
and then you've experienced those problems
so then you have this filing cabinet in your brain
where you can say like here's all the things that I know of
already that can go wrong
and that can help you better prepare for the next one
where maybe those things happen again but also
maybe something brand new.
Listen through it.
but also having collecting all those experiences
you know when things get tough like I've been here before.
Yeah.
And this is what I did or I got through it
so I know I can get through it again.
Yeah for sure I'll think that if I'm
like puking in the bushes I can open up a whole folder
in this filing cabinet of times I've been
throwing up during a race and like
then the options that I have of what worked before
or what I at least tried before.
Right I feel like you need to get into a lab
and have some test run
like they've done tests on Killian they
know he has a crazy threshold.
Alex Honnold has had his brain yeah analyzed
and they realize he his brain is a little bit different
when it comes to his fear response
like I feel like we need to get
Dr. Andrew Huberman my neuroscience buddy
to test your head and see what's going on
or like do you like have you had all those markers
evaluated so you know where you are?
You haven't even done that, right?
Like I feel like let's get you in the lab
let's figure out what's going on.
What if they only find air
but that would be instructive too, right?
Now we know you know.
Like yeah like either you have some genetic disposition
that differentiates you and even if you don't
that's super interesting also.
Because then it does then it does I think in my mind
that tells me oh this person has developed
a mental toughness that you can't calibrate
with any scientific rigor
and that's interesting to explore in and of itself.
Yeah I would be curious what they would be like
testing for or looking for.
Well they could test your like
I mean you're not wearing a watch right now
I'm not sure about-
How do you measure crazy?
Yeah I know right I don't know,
I don't know maybe some scientist knows how to do that
it's not crazy but they could test your aerobic threshold
and your resting heart rate and your heart rate variability
and like all of that kind of stuff that you ignore.
Yeah.
You wear a watch though when you're running don't you?
I do.
You wear
a heart rate monitor?
Nope I just have the one that's built into the watch
but I don't really use heart rate.
Just go with the joy.
Is that surprising?
No it's not surprising at all
like I kind of love it, its great.
I think I have a good gauge of effort.
I'm sure you know yeah
it's like you're so connected to yourself
that you don't need that
because you already know intuitively
where you're at, right?
And that comes with experience you've been doing this
for a long time.
Pretty long.
Yeah, I mean when did you
you started running cross country
in junior high, high school.
Yeah cross country starting in middle school
and then cross country skiing through high school.
Yeah and you were a state champion
in cross-country skiing.
Yeah.
Were you?
Why are you like laughing?
(both laughing)
why is that so funny.
It's not I'm just awkward.
(Courtney laughs)
You're not awkward relax we're just having fun here
it's all good, it's all good.
It seems like your parents are really
supportive and cool.
Yeah they're the best they're amazing.
I was watching the video that Salomon made
around the Western states with your parents there
they were so cute being interviewed.
They were so fired up to get to see this race
where it's like kind of there's so many crowds
and so much excitement around it so,
I was really lucky they could come out for it.
Ever since I started doing these ultras they've been full on
supportive and like the first 100-mile race
that I ended up finishing.
So my second one I had signed up for,
it was just my dad and brother and Kevin
as my crew none of us knew what we were doing
and we're like up in the woods of Minnesota
at the Superior 100 like figuring out
what these Aid stations are
and what the trail looks like
and how to even like go about getting to a finish line.
Yeah I think there's this misconception that you
like won your first race
and it's just been podiums ever since but you started
in what like 2012 running ultras and it was a couple years
of you growing and learning before you hit your stride
and started winning.
For sure yeah it took a lot of races to start to put
the pieces together.
Did you know with that first one then though
that like oh this is gonna be my thing.
No I think so I just stumbled upon the ultra running world
I had no idea they existed
and there was a 50k at a Local Park
so I signed up for that
and was intrigued by it but I wasn't like hooked
on the sport right away
and then I did a 50-mile race a little bit later that year
and that got me hooked all the way
and then I just wanted to know
what else was out there and what could I try.
What was the decision to sign up for the first race though
why were you interested to begin with?
So I did a road marathon
and surprised myself by finishing it
like I didn't think I'd actually get to the finish line
of 26.2 miles I thought my legs would shatter
I thought I would die on the side of this road
and when I finished it
it kind of like flipped a switch for me
of just wondering if that sounded too hard
but I did it what else is there that sounds too hard
that I could try.
So I tried like a tough mudder then
and then stumbled upon like these races
that were just a smidge longer
then a road marathon a 50k,
what five miles more I was like I gotta try and see
if the extra five miles kills me
and then I did it.
Well if that didn't kill me.
Exactly yeah so then it was a real quick progression
I did the 50-mile race got hooked and didn't die
and then instantly I wanted to try 100 miles.
It really fits your your disposition though because
as somebody who is all about intuitive feel
to be a marathon runner is really kind of
a data driven thing like oh here are the workouts
you need to do and here's how you have to hit your splits
but trail running is all about
the terrain dictating everything
so all of that goes out the window
and it's just about like being present in the experience
and tackling things as as they're thrown at you
it's not about anyone else other than you and you.
Yeah I think in that 50k I was so surprised that
everyone was chatting out on this trail
winding through the woods
no one's watches were beeping splits
and then at aid stations we got to just fill our pockets
with jelly beans I was like I'm in.
(both laughing)
We're gonna talk about your garbage patch kids diet
in a minute.
I feel like we have a lot in common there.
Yeah oh my goodness.
(Courtney laughs)
You're young there's more to learn.
It is interesting as somebody who's trying to to achieve
peak performance in all these areas
that your approach is to not focus on all these things
where people are trying to get that incremental advantage
whether it's through some scientific approach to training
or a dietary approach like you're just like no,
not doing that
I eat whatever nachos, cheeseburgers, french fries.
So good.
Candy right?
Has that evolved at all?
No.
No and I realized like that is definitely an area where
maybe if I did something differently maybe it would help but
then like weighing that against how much joy
I get out of just living life like this
I just I love nachos too much.
I don't blame you I'm not I'm like I got nothing but love
Okay.
For that.
I think the enjoyment piece is really important
because if you're not enjoying yourself
then you're putting a shelf life on your career
and if it becomes too rigorous
or restricted whether it's through training
or diet or any other like sleeping in an altitude tent
like all these like you don't even use Normatec boots right?
No.
Is that not changed.
Yeah I was broken
he couldn't remember what they were called but
like that's something that is like De rigueur
with endurance athletes
and you were like I don't even know what that is.
(both laughing)
like that's nuts but the good thing is
if you ever get interested in those things
then there's a whole world of opportunity
and possibility ahead of you.
Yeah.
To explore all that stuff.
I'll just keep them in my back pocket.
Right yeah pull it out when you need it
but so far so good, right?
Let's talk about the Barkley marathons.
Yeah let's.
I'm fascinated by this race
and the people involved and what this is all about
so explain what it is for people who've never heard of it.
So it's a race in the mountains of Tennessee
outside of a prison and I believe the history came about
because a prisoner escaped this prison
and when he was found 60 hours later
he had only made it like five miles or something
from the prison
and so Lazarus lake is the race director
and I guess him and his buddies were just jaw boning
about how they would make it farther
and they should then make this race out there.
So it's not marked like a normal ultra marathon is
and it's not on actual trails it's just bushwhacking
through these mountains
and you have to complete five 20-ish mile loops
in order to be a finisher of the Barclay marathons.
You say 20-ish because they say it's 20 but it's not 20.
It's not 20, but maybe 25 or 26 mile loops not positive
and the way you prove that
you made it around the loop correctly is
he's hidden books out in the woods
and you have to get to the book
and then you rip out your bib number
to prove you were at that book
and then turn them in when you finish your loop.
Right.
And it's uncrewed there's no aid stations.
The only time you can get more things is when you're back
at the camp between loops and then there's a few stops
out on the course where he's put some jugs of water.
And over is it five loops total.
Five loops total.
To complete it
and there's something like 60,000 feet
of elevation gain, right?
Yeah easily I bet.
I now its a lot.
So you're out there it's not marked
you don't really know where you're going
I mean people are getting lost all the time, right?
Yeah.
The weather's terrible.
The weather is horrendous
and you're navigating just with a compass
and the day before the race he puts out his map
that you copy onto your own map
of like the line you're supposed to take.
It's not a orienteering race it's not like
you can just go any direction through these woods
to get to the books you're supposed to follow his line.
And isn't it a thing where he doesn't tell you
when it's gonna start.
Yeah he gives you a one-hour of warning
so it can be anywhere in this like I don't know
12-hour window of time or something 20-hour window of time
and he'll give you the one-hour warning
and this year I was lucky enough to get to try the race
and he gave that warning at like 2 A.M or something.
Right 3 A.M start.
Yeah.
He lights the cigarette which is the thing he does
I mean he's the character of this guy,
what's the story with this dude?
(Courtney laughs)
controversial too.
Yeah he's a character,
but he's created all these events where like
he just wants to help people see what's possible for them
so like Barkley is that you know people sign up for it
knowing they're not gonna finish probably I think in total
there's been 15 finishers ever of the Barkley
and then he's created the Big's Backyard
where it's like run till you can't basically so.
15 people total finish,
I thought it was a few more than that I don't know
but no woman has done the whole
has completed the whole thing
is that correct right?
Correct yeah.
And when you did it you did
you completed the first loop within the time limit
and then on the second loop came in like
on 12 minutes too late.
Yep we're 12 minutes over the cutoff
so we weren't allowed to then leave on our third loop.
so there's-
Did anybody finish?
No two people made it the fun run which is three loops.
So they I think it's like 40 hours
you have to get three loops done
in order to count for a fun run.
Right but it doesn't actually count as.
Right yeah.
So this is like the only race where almost
where basically nobody finishes like every single year.
Yeah.
How long has it been going on?
A long time.
Yeah.
I mean I'm not sure.
We can look that up.
I know are you gonna go back to that?
You got to crack that.
I'm really intrigued by it like just getting my feet wet
and getting to actually see what it's all about
was really cool.
I mean it's just as hard as as everyone says like
it's just straight up and down these mountain sides
and then finding the books is like this silly game
where they're like hidden in the most obscure places
like it's like in a hole, under a rock, on this log,
like it's hard to find them.
I can't imagine like being that tired
and it's like dark out too, right?
Yeah.
So you have this map
and you're like the book's supposed to be here
and you can't find it.
Yeah, luckily I was with veterans
and so they had a better gauge
on like the lay of the land
and just having been there before
like there's some spots that he repeats
the book being hidden there
so they knew like,
oh we lift up this one rock
and then it's wherever but like the whole first half
of the first loop this year was in the dark
and then it was in the fog
and so everyone going to the race had told me
pay attention on that first loop figure out your landmarks
so that when you do it again on the
second loop you start to piece it together
and you can like see the land in your head
and where you're going kind of
and that whole first half of the first loop I'm like,
I couldn't see like 10 feet out
I'm like guys I'm really trying to see
the landmarks.
Oh my God.
So all right a couple questions
first of all the map that you have is that on a
like a an iPhone with a GPS or is on a piece of paper.
No technology so.
Right so you can't see
your dot on thing and to make sure
that you're on course.
Yeah no phones, no GPS watches he issues you.
It is an orienteering race then he said
it's not but it kind of is.
Kind of except in orienteering can't
they go however to get to the point?
Oh I don't know.
'Cause this is like a very specific path
to get to the book that you're supposed to follow.
So maybe it's a little bit orienteering
but not like a free-for-all like.
Did he change it up like could you go
at other parts of the year and train on the course
so you get familiar
with all the rock formations and everything.
You can train off trail in the park
and so like the park makes a special exception
for this race every year to happen off trail
but otherwise during the year you have to stay on
just their normal park trails.
Right.
But this year the watch he gave us was a like pocket watch
like clicks open with the lid
and it was so useless.
Right and isn't it that like the entry fee
is like a $1.60 or something
and then there's always some random thing also
like a license plate.
What's that all about.
Yep license plate.
If you're new to the race
you have to bring a license plate that year
and then if you've done the race before
there's like a different thing you bring him
I think he's done like socks and cigarettes
and whatever else.
Great oh my God.
Yeah it's pretty cool though
I mean it was just like
it was silly the weather was so bad
that a few times I was with this small group
we were just going up and down these hillsides
and everyone's just slipping everywhere
there's mud down the whole hillside
and so like zooming out and watching it
I'm like this is like a comedy movie
like people are just slipping and falling and like tumbling
and then back on their feet and running like
it was the most normal thing to be doing.
Right, right, right, well I'm wondering whether
there's something so beautiful and pure about that
but also balancing that against risk and liability
as this sport is continuing to grow
like it's very much in its juvenile years in terms of
what we're learning about what's physically
and mentally possible
but also in terms of onboarding all of these
enthusiastic runners who are looking to push their limits
and we just saw what happened in China recently
where 21 people died
and when it's fun to talk oh we're sliding around in mud
but like there's real life you know ramifications of this
where people can get seriously hurt we saw that
and it's going to be interesting to see
how that impacts race directors
and races going forward in the United States
like it's a cautionary tale like this is very real
and people are pushing themselves to places that
not everybody's ready to go.
Yeah.
And they can be inspired by you but if they're not
somebody who's been doing this for a long time
people can get into very real trouble pretty quickly.
For sure yeah.
And like just because it's this marked course
doesn't give you this bubble of safety around it
like it's still mountains and there's still.
Yeah and you're in these remote places,
there's no hospitals nearby and most of these races
remain very grassroots there's just a couple people there.
There's not a lot of infrastructure
and that's what makes it great
and cool and fun and cultivates this amazing community
and rapport that you have with everybody
but on some level there is a,
sure this is that event makes me think like well
maybe it's time to mature a little bit.
Yeah or yeah I don't know if like
the application process needs more
information from each runner to see.
Stronger waivers its your fault.
But also like can you make smart choices
out there like what's your wilderness training
or experience in that kind of thing
I don't know what the solution is but
it's scary how real it became
when something like that race happens.
And at the same time there's money coming
into the sport we just saw iron man partnering with UTMB
which is another controversial thing
like how do you feel about that.
I'm not sure I don't know.
I guess we don't know yet, right?
Yeah.
You'll probably learn more
when you go to the race this year.
Yeah we'll all we have-
What aspects of the race are gonna be impacted by it
positively or negatively.
Yeah we'll see.
Yeah you're gonna be very politic here.
(Courtney laughs)
I mean it's hard it's hard to know right now
I think the fear is that it will corrupt the integrity of it
on the positive side there's an infusion of money
that could make the sport better
and create opportunities for more runners and the like
but I think protecting the integrity and the legacy
and what makes ultra running and that community special
is important and so I think people are afraid that
that partnership could threaten that.
Yeah and I mean I'm not even trying to stay neutral
I feel like I've just read a lot of things
where it's like guessing what might happen.
Right all these hot takes but we don't know yet
we don't know we'll see soon enough, right?
Yeah.
What is your, of the two races that you're preparing for
right now let's talk about the differences
between something like Hard Rock and UTMB
because they're they're very different.
Yeah the courses will be kind of similar
I mean they're both mountain terrain lots of climbing
but just the races in general are all the way different.
Hardrock has like 150 people in the race,
UTMB has thousands and thousands.
It's crazy the crowds that show up for that.
Yeah I mean I've only been over there once
but it was insane I've never experienced anything like that
but I'm excited to have both of them
I think it's so cool when you roll into an aid station
that's just a folding table out in the middle of nowhere
with some volunteers that camped there the night before
to get there I think that's just as special
as like rolling through a hyped up town with
crazy tents and NASCAR style crewing.
So it'll be fun to have these races that are both
beautiful mountain 100-mile races but then different
in so many other ways.
And what does the training look like in between the two
are you just trying to like recover as much as possible
so you can be fresh?
Yeah I think that'll be really play it by hear
and see what my body needs and how my brain is feeling.
Maybe some weeks of training squeezed in there
but maybe it'll just be like recovering
and then trying to show up as fresh as possible at UTMB.
Well I guess you'll just wake up in the morning
and figure it out, right?
Yeah after coffee.
(Courtney laughs)
It's cool I can't wait to see what you're gonna do
do you feel like you shoulder a little bit more pressure
and a sense of expectations now because
of your accomplishments does it change how you
approach these races?
For me it doesn't no I mean I expect from myself
to give it everything I have
and so what someone else is expecting from me
is like not part of the equation.
Yeah that's pretty healthy.
I'll do my very best no matter what.
That's a a healthy mental approach.
I mean we're I don't know if you saw this this past weekend
with Naomi Osaka like refusing to do press.
Yeah I just saw that.
For her mental health which made the internet explode.
Yeah.
But I thought it was really cool that she's like listen
I'm not a product and I need to protect myself
and why should I expose myself to all of these
reporters who say negative things
and that affects my ability to perform
and I think it's created a really
interesting conversation about
the responsibility of the media
and the empowerment of the athlete
to like say no to this stuff like just because you're
competing at this level doesn't mean that you
owe anybody anything.
Yeah super interesting G dropped out of the tournament
now I think right?
Yeah I think so yeah.
How old is she do you know?
I don't know I should know she's young though?
Pretty young.
Yeah yeah yeah but that was a bold
that was a courageous thing to do I think
and there were a lot of the people on the other side
saying this is your job.
This goes with the territory you should know this
and on some level yes you make yourself available
to the press but doesn't that need to be reasonable
and within certain parameters and can't we respect
the sovereignty of the athlete
when they say enough is enough.
Yeah probably all the social media
changes the dynamics of sports.
What is your approach to social media
like do you feel like you need to be sharing stuff
and you've got sponsors
and people that want you to be kind of out there
in that way.
Yeah I mean I'm sort of I feel sort of new to it still
but I just it's a cool way to connect with people
is how I view it and so like,
I am having fun sharing my story using it
because maybe it can connect with someone who
maybe it helps them try something hard
I don't know and I mean my sponsors are fantastic
so I don't have pressure from them to like
do a certain thing or.
Yeah Salomon is your main sponsor.
That's correct.
Yeah you know I just joined the Salomon team
I'm so excited.
Now we gotta go running.
I think we're gonna
announce it tomorrow.
I'm super excited about it.
No it's hilarious like oh joining the Salomon family
I'm like with people like Courtney
like I don't like I'm way in the back like
I can't even believe that I'm here but
I'm really excited about it
and I love all the people that I've met
and gotten to spend a little bit of time with
and everything is just so dialed in and super pro
from the gear to just the integrity
and it's been really it's like a dream come true for me.
Oh that's so cool.
So Aaron and Juris were supposed to come out
and do the Iron Cowboy thing with me the other day
but their young end wasn't feeling well
so they couldn't do it but
I was hoping to see them on Saturday.
They're so great.
Yeah.
I'm so pumped
you're on the team.
I know I should figure out some kind of
I feel like I have I really have to live up.
No.
(both laughs)
I got to find some kind of challenge for myself
or whatever to legitimize the relationship.
I'm really proud,
I'm really proud.
What would it be?
Would you want to do a Backyard race?
Maybe I have to put in quite a bit of work
between now and maybe in a year I have to get ready
I gotta heal my back up.
If you had to choose between a Backyard or a 200.
I think I can wrap my head around a Backyard.
Yeah that's what's cool about it is that
it can be as as hard as your body is able to go, right?
And those little breaks become super significant.
And mentally it's not as intimidating.
Yeah it is a cool format I mean,
the first year I was there I think,
there was a person who was like.
I'm just gonna try to run my first marathon ever today
and they wanted to stay in to get their 26 miles
and then they were gonna feel satisfied
and they ended up doing I think 100k like 62 miles
because four miles at a time they just kept thinking like
oh I can do one more, I can do one more.
Yeah I think the the Goggins challenge
where he did the four by four by 48 was a similar thing
because it feels bite-sized
and you don't realize that it's actually hard
when you think about it until you're
actually doing it and you're in the middle of the night
Right.
And it encourages people to try something that maybe
they would have been too intimidated to do
if it was signing up for like a really long race.
Yeah absolutely.
Yeah I wanna think of something
like create my own thing though too
like I think there's something cool about that
and if there was a silver lining
to the pandemic with respect to ultras
it was the like Backyard, the Backyard challenge thing
that was was Mike Wardian the one who created that
he's the one who went the furthest.
To do the virtual Backyard.
Yeah the virtual thing.
Yeah went the furthest
he was our Dave Proctor and his team in Canada
who like put together the event.
Yeah those things are cool.
Yeah.
To be able to create community
when we couldn't be together.
Yeah oh it was so fun.
Well I know.
It felt like we were all hanging out together
even though I was just staring at this little screen.
I know right I know.
Well it must be nice to feel like you can
start traveling now and the world is opening up a little bit
and all that.
Yeah it feels awesome.
Like seeing people doing things I think though like
I kind of liked last year
and like finding appreciation in these trails
that were right out my door all the time
that I had gotten taking them for granted basically
and then being stuck at home all last Spring
and into the Summer it was like
oh there's a lot of cool link-ups
you can actually make if you're just looking for it.
Right it encouraged you to explore a little bit more.
Yeah and I saw way more families out on the trails
and just getting outside more so
I think it could have some cool things come from it
even though it was definitely not great.
Amelia Boone lives in Golden also doesn't she
do you ever go running with her.
No I saw her during a virtual run I was doing
and we crossed paths on the trails
but otherwise we haven't run together.
Really didn't you but one of the
'cause the the the Backyard Ultra you do it in teams right?
That like the the U.S. has their team
and there was like wasn't Amelia part of one teams?
Yeah so we that was in person at in Tennessee in the Fall
we were able to share a ton of miles there
but never in Golden.
That's so that's funny yeah I feel like I had this
idea like oh you guys are like hanging out and running
and having coffee and doing stuff like that
all the time no.
No not recently, we should.
What is the ultra running community of the future
that you would like to see like
where is all this heading and like explain to somebody
who's listening or watching who's unfamiliar with this world
like what's great about it
and why maybe they should think of stepping into it.
Oh man so many reasons just exploring with your feet
like the places you end up with just your body
carrying you there is pretty cool
and it feels special to be in the middle of nowhere
and to have gotten yourself there on purpose.
I think it's the most welcoming community
my the first 50-mile race I did one of the things was
that hooked me was how awesome the people around me were
and I mean we were in hail and sleet and just awful weather
and people were wearing garbage bags as their raincoats
because it kept them a little bit warmer
and all signs pointed to like we should
be hating life right now
but people were just making the best of it
they were hooping and hollering, splashing through puddles
finding like all the joy they could
in this miserable situation
and they're also the most helpful because in that same race
I face planted in a mud puddle
and a person 15 yards ahead ran back offered their hand
and pulled me out of this puddle to keep running together
like where does that happen?
Yeah.
You went out of your way to help me
it's not just that I was conveniently in your way
like they turned around and came back for me.
Yeah that is something really unique
about the community I think.
And I find that in every race
I mean everyone's ready to help
if you're on the side of the trail having trouble
like everyone who goes by is going to ask
what can I do how can I help you to get back on track.
And you might even hallucinate and you could go blind.
Yeah also perks.
(both laughing)
Can we talk about the hallucinations.
Have you ever hallucinated.
No.
Yeah it's fun you make some good friends.
Yeah I like your it's for me
I mean you hear lots of stories of ultra
runners having hallucinations
but what I love about your hallucinations
is your relationship to them like they're like your friends
or something like you're like oh this is awesome
there's Mickey Mouse over there doing whatever like
what is going on.
Mickey Mouse was throwing out T-shirts to the crowd
and he did not throw me one.
(Courtney laughs)
Do you know they're not real when they're happening
so there's a detachment
or are you thinking this is really real
and it's still cool for the most part now I can tell
they're not real there are some instances
where I have to like take double or triple takes
at something because I can't believe I'm seeing these
people dancing right there and like what are they doing.
But usually I can recognize it's not real
and it means that I'm doing something really cool
because these friends don't just come out anytime.
Right it's special.
Yeah.
Here they come,
do you know it's always gonna
happen at hour or whatever.
It's not a certain hour but it's
definitely over 24 hours of effort
and then like night time for sure brings out more friends.
So like UTMB starts in the evening
and so the night is when you're a little bit fresher
and so I made no friends at UTMB because.
You're like where are my friends.
Yeah even though that course would be hard enough
and take long enough where I maybe I would have made them
if the night had been at the end section.
I think you're a very healthy person I'm no shrink
but I think the the the sort of good-natured aspect
of your hallucinations speak to somebody
who's you know a very grounded individual
like if it was a lot of demons coming out at night
and people trying to kill you and stuff like
I feel like you should write them all down
and then you could give that journal to a psychiatrist
and say tell me who I am.
Yeah I don't know if I want them to analyze it
but I had to my friend Maggie who does Big's Backyard
and all sorts of adventures she has really scary ones
like she sees like heads on spears
and clowns and stuff.
Right.
I'm like Maggie you gotta watch happy movies
the day before like she's watching IT
the night before a race.
Yeah Annabelle
Yeah I'm like what do you think you're gonna see?
(Courtney laughs)
That's funny what about the blindness though.
Explain that story for people that don't know it.
Yeah I don't recommend it,
but what happened was it was a 100 mile race
and about 12 miles from the finish my vision
was just getting really foggy on the edges.
I thought it was my contact lenses
I thought it was my headlamp dying
like I couldn't figure out what was going on
but I for sure noticed I was seeing less and less
and by 10 miles out from the finish line
it just had closed in all the way where it was pure white
in my field of vision.
Like I waved my hand in front of my face
and I couldn't see my hand.
But there were 10 miles left and so it was like,
problem solving figuring out what solutions I had as options
to keep moving forward.
I didn't ever feel like it was permanent
because it had crept in like it did
and it didn't come from like falling and hitting my head
it had just like slowly happened over time.
So I determined it was safe
and then if I just stared down at my toes
I could see this tiny arc of the trail in front of them
to keep moving
as quickly as possible.
So you could see enough
to gauge your foot placement.
Yes I could see that I was on the trail still
and I knew that section of trail I knew there weren't
like spurs off of it where I would end up lost
or I knew it didn't cliff out anywhere
so I was like if I can just stay on this single track
it'll be okay.
Right you're not gonna fall off a cliff.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I mean some areas if that happened
I would sit like if it's an area where it does clip out
or if I'm unfamiliar with what it does
I would probably have to like make a different choice.
Yeah.
'Cause I'm not trying to go off a cliff anywhere.
I hope not.
Yeah but then I made it to an Aid station
with about six miles left
and the volunteers were very kind
and sent one of their Aid station workers
to run next to me and she narrated the trail to me then
and so she was like.
Oh my God.
There is big rocks
on your left, the trail is turning slightly to the right
and it just made it so much easier because
I could like sort of then predict with my body
where I was going next.
When I was by myself it was I was falling everywhere
because if you can't see in front of your feet
I mean I was landing on every rock and route
and just tripping on everything.
I don't even know where to begin with this so.
Yeah I don't know if you should maybe we just leave that.
You're like all right moving on next question.
(both laughing)
I mean come on first of all you're wearing contacts
for like days on end right probably not a smart idea.
Yes.
You probably stopped
doing that after that, right?
No because I can't see without them.
But you can get like I'm blind as a bat
you just get glasses.
Oh I could do that.
Yeah right I've heard LASIK makes it happen more often.
It's corneal edema that's what's happening, right?
So essentially your body's so under so much stress
that you're having this immune response
creating inflammation in your eyes
that is crowding out your ability to see
like it's basically pressure on the optic nerve.
Yeah and they I mean the best diagnosis
or reason they said is probably that and it was dusty
and smokey air and like rubbing my eyes
maybe just aggravated.
You mean like
allergic response.
Yeah.
But the frame of mind when that happens to not freak out
and say I gotta stop like I can't see
and you're like oh it's good we'll just keep going
like I think it's gonna be okay
it was so great I had a guide like that's not normal.
Right you recognize that.
Yes and I like I don't recommend people just do this
like maybe make the choice for you
if it ever happens to your eyes
like figure out how you feel about all the factors
you know but.
But when it happened you didn't know
what corneal edema was like now if it happens again
you're like this has happened before
or I read something about it
but when it was occurring in real time
most people would have just freaked out.
Yeah I think in general how I try to stay is
just without emotions in situations like that so
like what are the facts of this situation
and then what can I actually control about it.
How long before your eyesight returned?
It was probably like five or six hours after the finish.
That's a long time to be sitting there
like at hour four like is this gonna work out.
I was very happy when it came back
I went to the hospital so I mean they checked me out
they weren't worried about the eyes.
Oh okay that's helpful.
Yeah.
So what do you do, is there anything you do now
to help prevent that like drops or anything like that.
Yeah I do eye drops pretty much through every Ultra.
Now I'll have them in my pack
or I'll use them at Aid stations
and then protective eyewear
so just trying to keep out as much dust as possible.
But still with the contacts.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah I don't know I don't maybe I could try glasses.
Have you never worn glasses?
Not really oh I've never really worn contacts.
Yeah maybe we can switch.
Lets do us all-
I'll start wearing contacts
and I'll give you my glasses
and we'll see
how that works out.
Yeah perfect.
Maybe I'll get like really good at Ultra's
and then you'll your back will start hurting you.
(both laughing)
Thank you sounds like a good trade.
We can wrap this up in a few minutes
but I one thing we're starting to lose the thread.
One thing I'm interested in is
as somebody who's out there pushing the envelope
in your sport showing the rest of us what's possible
and breaking all these boundaries and barriers
how does that affect your mental disposition
and how you approach other facets of your life
like how does it spill over
and how you think about possibilities
and potential in areas that are outside of running.
I think it's possible in every area outside of running
I'm not like seeking it in any other area right now
but I think what it's shown me is that like
people are selling themselves short
and setting their bars too low
of what they could actually do
if they went all in on something
whatever they're psyched about to just see
what happens if they invest a little more time
and energy into it.
And what about for yourself?
For myself?
See you deflected
a little bit there.
What never.
Because I was asking
about you too.
I never do that.
Yeah I know.
Like am I pursuing am I.
Well right now you're all in on running, right?
This is 110 all your focus and all your time
but there are other interests I'm sure that you have
and you're married and you have a relationship
and I'm sure there's other goals
that maybe you're thinking about for your life
after running or in conjunction with your running.
Talk a little bit about that
and how you kind of see your life unfolding.
I don't know how I see it unfolding.
'Cause you're just here right where your feet are.
Yeah what I know is.
You I wake up in the morning
and decide.
Yeah I'm having,
like I love this chapter that it's in right now
and so just enjoying that fully and knowing like
chapters don't go on forever so this ride
you know will end at some point
and what comes next I'm not sure.
But I hope whatever you know page it flips to next
I can be just as excited about finding out what's possible.
Right, but you don't have a sense
of what that might look like.
I don't know no, do you think I should?
Not necessarily I think you should be you.
Okay.
I think it's working out fine.
(Courtney laughs)
Yeah I don't know.
Well I no I think that's interesting
that you asked me that because people ask me that
what where do you, what's the next thing
or where do you see yourself in five years
and I don't really approach my life that way
I really don't think about those things
then I feel guilty because like
here's my five-year plan like should I have a five-year plan
I don't know.
Do you so you don't have a five-year plan.
No.
You have a weekly plan.
I have a schedule of things that I'm doing
but everything that ends up on the calendar
is a reflection of me
I mean I'm in a very privileged place
where I have the opportunity to seek out things
that interest me and pursue my curiosity
whether that's in sport or with the podcast
or other creative outlets and not everybody has that
kind of life so I'm very grateful for that but
it's all about like oh this is cool
let's see what this is about
rather than like I'm working towards this thing
and there's a destination and it's gonna look like that
when I get there like I don't function that way.
Yeah that's cool me neither.
Yeah I don't get that well but at the same time you do
like well you say these are the races I'm gonna do this year
and I'm working towards my best performance of them.
So they're anchored,
you're those are like the anchors
and then your life kind of orients around that
but within that there's so much opportunity
to be flexible and intuitive about your approach.
Yeah for sure.
Yeah one of the things that you see in ultra running
is a problem with longevity in careers
like you see athletes who come onto the scene
they crush it they have a window of time a couple years
where they're indestructible
they're just winning everything in sight
and then something happens
and they can't quite match those performances anymore
I've seen it mostly in men time and time and time again
and I've often thought like what is causing that
or why is that
and I'm not sure anybody knows the answer to that
but obviously you're aware that this is the case
so do you think at all about how you can protect
the longevity of what you're trying to accomplish
like do you put any effort into that or thought.
Yeah I wanna be doing the sport as long as possible
and I mean my schedule,
my race schedule four years ago
would have been an ultra every month
because I love it so much
and I just wanted to do this thing I love
and also I felt good doing it so why not sign up for more
but have wisened a little bit over the years
to ease back on asking my body to go to that place
so many times a year and also I mean I had an injury
a few years ago that taught me to not neglect
the small things like core work
or stretching foam rolling like things like that.
I now implement because it's this tiny change I can do
to maybe keep me in the sport longer.
Yeah I think I remember when you're on Rogan
he asked you about stretching
and you're like yeah I should probably should
but I don't really so there's a change, right?
You're growing wiser.
Yeah a little bit.
Yeah but it's life's lumps that force you to
make those adjustments.
Yeah for sure.
Yeah well soon the diet
we'll talk about that.
(both laughing)
Yeah we can talk about it.
We'll see no I'm not getting involved you're doing fine
and are you still like you don't know
no supplements or anything like that
No nothing.
Just candy bars.
Yeah mostly jelly beans.
Jelly beans yeah the fruity candy is my favorite
and it's getting vitamins in there somehow so.
And then when you're out training
like with a hydration pack
what is it's tailwind like what is your go-to.
Tailwind, honey stinger and then if it's a race
I'll probably have some mashed potatoes in my pack
and then if it's a really long race then it's like
any other carbs, pizza burgers, pancakes,
pierogies really good.
McDonald's french fries.
So good yeah.
The salt, right?
Yeah I mean yeah and really any form of potato
tastes great during ultra.
Yeah they work well they're effective for sure.
Well I'm excited to see these races unfold with you.
Thank you.
It's pretty cool, which shoe are you gonna wear?
Probably the S-lab Ultra three have you tried it?
I haven't tried that one yet.
I've been running in the the Ultra glide the new shoe
that's about to come out.
So good.
Yeah it's great, right?
Yeah.
Enjoying that I like the the Sense very much too
those are what I'm wearing right now I think.
The Sense ride.
Yeah they're great.
I need I gotta try those S-labs though
I haven't I haven't run in those.
I'm so happy you're on the team.
Thank you.
Its exciting.
I'm very proud I feel unworthy,
all right so I want to live up to it.
You're very worthy.
Yeah I'm, I was nervous and awkward and scared myself
to talk to you because I have so much respect
for everything that you do and you're such a joy
and a pleasure to speak to
and I wish you only the best.
Well thank you.
Yeah and I look forward to spending a little bit more time
with you and getting to know you
and being a cheerleader for your success.
Thank you, yeah let's run some trails today.
I would love to do that I don't know my guy's here
I got a lot of work to do
I don't know if I can talk my way out of the office
but I'll see what I can do.
Yeah they won't know.
Cool so if people want to connect with you,
what's the best way for them to find you on the internet
basically if you type in her name in Google there's plenty
yeah in Instagram maybe.
Yeah on Instagram @courtneydauwalter.
Awesome.
It would be great.
All right well come back after these races
and tell me about it
Yeah I would love that cool.
Peace.
(upbeat music)